what was life like
why did you kick carina like that
carina he has to apologize did you do
something before
that wanted to start a fight can we
still say that i can say exactly
where the fight started none of
you are sitting in your place and that’s why
I won't deny for anyone for now
when I come in you're all
running around either you're sitting on the seat
you don't have to teach an extra class in the
first class it's like
standing in line at Mercedes for eight hours
because it just makes you feel like that  so
exhausted that 20 children ask everything and of
course you have to stay calm because they
arrive without prior knowledge and not
with as many social skills as
many of these eight hours
there are unfortunately 66 times eight what
feels like 48 hours of instruction in the end
nothing comes  out and maybe
i'll never find out if any of the
kids here ever got their high school diploma because of
the contact too  breaks off after the
fourth grade
but that wouldn't necessarily be the case at other
schools it's exactly but then
you had time with the kids noticed when
we did this project it was
so great it was so nice although i
'll probably remember it
sooner  mostly positive
i find it loud when the boy had such a
burden and broke down
here i
mastered it
so my memory of being proud of
myself doing loss of assets at that
moment and not coming home with a lot of
radiant moments beam
is maybe different  school year
so if you go out alone sabina
if you say once but just
do it please he
is right the most important
rule is respect
the children need attention from
their parents the children need
attention from people they
trust and encouragement in
their own time to  play
free time let ideas be
guided children  we need fairy tales and stories
that wet the children
sara is doing well because lisa is doing well
so we already
know or maybe we don't know where
samir is where zambia is where is
we saw on which continent of our world
does a man get in touch where then show  times where
is in africa
you can see exactly that africa and do
you think zambia we have there i
don't think that if aldi comes along from expenses
who is coming then renovate zambia
exactly i'll put it so that your
head is with australia exactly what's there
work in the zambian mine instead of
going to school today
what do you want to do do you want to work
in the office as what so what do you need
and i am i no school leaving certificate and
then i need an apprenticeship or
maybe even an internship even
bigger where i was a university  what do
you do at the university a studio
maybe even need a degree and should
I tell you something really sad what i read h  but
those from Kattenturm Mitte only have 24
children out of 20 going to do a
degree is not so bad for Chemnitz
the power an apprenticeship
maybe you are 154 children don't
keep your fingers crossed
it was the bridge that I had to cross as a
child you just have to  on the other hand
it has involved the extremely rich to the
social hot spot
overcoming to go over the bridge
why put simply are drug addicts
i was somehow really afraid that
the parents would not let me play with the children
if really aware of that
i come from there i come from this
quarter so I tried
to adapt to that report I coop how how
eat how behave and
I just don't want that either what you
don't play with me anymore did
push-ups with the one who lives on the side of the bridge
and the girl
kinda put it on her  back legs
pulled away and totally name faces
i said that sucked and this kid
stopped immediately  and he heard
this situation didn't
escalate further and it has never worked so well to
somehow
de-escalate a situation as on the day when i
said that was [ __ ] so
i used their language i
didn't want to humiliate the child either and something like that
worked
you carry on it was
my idea was it's my idea
to talk to the children like that because if I
say so often today I do
n't want to
let it be, then
the situation escalates sometimes it takes
so much strength from me because I'm in that
momentarily I have an impulse to talk to the
children like that because I am a bit
afraid of disciplinary
proceedings from parents who are standing on the mat
but to be honest I know how
the children talk to each other and that
the parents talk to their children in the same way,
so it can be the case  he doesn't even
knock on my door but if i
can reach so ott
da
give
wales
hennessy casey
help
i h  but i sometimes listened to pink's album is understood a
thousand times at least 100 times in a row
i
totally
identified with it do you feel do you sometimes feel like you're a
permanent employee at school yes at school
i really sometimes sympathize because i have
the feeling i'm leaving  yes, often from a
completely different side, so with the
heart, maybe it's the deficit from
before, sometimes I thought I have to
fight harder than the others, it's still too
big and then I think I
just can't say that much because I
don't have the right  somehow giving my two
cents to be an intuitive partner
and then i sometimes feel a little
different there but i think it has to
stop you just have to know that i
've really made it one step
further no longer the little
girl
wesel used to be,
no